this is the theme but angels this is the
thesis the biju the smell out hundred
Allah greetings of peace peace be to you
and you're watching the D show emitter
your host when we come back alia is back
on the Dean show the Muslim youth are
learning Islam and Islam the more we
learn it the more we implement it the
more better is our life the more it
teaches us how how to be the best human
beings that you can be and we're going
to talk to one of those little Muslims
and we come back here on the Dean show
sit tight don't go nowhere this is the
team the d
this is the thing is the teacher this is
the age of 15 jus this is the he's be
unto you how are you alia good good
thank you for coming back to the Dean
show we did a show before and how did
you how to come out did you did your
friends watch it the people see you on
the Dean show yeah did you get a chance
to share it with some of the not yet
Muslims yeah what was their response and
then I did too great great so for the
people that don't know about you already
then go to the Dean show calm and you
know they can watch the first show that
we did now you're a you're an author
with the help of your parents you've
written how many books I've written four
books and I'm my pistol isn't printing
what do they call it again the first
place called things every kid should
know smoking the second one is called
things every kid should know drugs the
third one is called things every kid
should know bullying and the fourth one
is called things every kitchen or
alcohol and the fifth one is called
things every kid should know junk food
ok so in your books your teaching kids
how to smoke how to eat junk food what's
the best junk food how to be a bully is
that what your books are about time I
actually trying to help them avoid this
avoid those things cuz you said ok
because you said things every kid should
know is not how to believe how to smoke
how to drink not that how to not do that
ok cool why I mean we cover some of
these things before but just kind of to
you know recap these books are they
meant to they're really meant to help
keep kids away from these bad things
what if someone says look this is I mean
I think it's good for me you know
alcohol makes me feel good
well my field made me I like make you
feel good right then that's not really
good through the long runs mm-hmm and
smoking same thing you know what about
parents they're smoking and they're
telling their knock their kids not to
smoke what do you got to say to the
parents who are you know being bad
examples well if you're doing it that I
don't know how your kid is taking into a
forensic it's strong enough you know not
to do it you know but I think where our
kids more likely gonna have a chance of
doing it because you're doing it and so
your kid is watching you do I think the
more that I have the chance of doing it
so be a good example lead by example
okay don't smoke don't drink and don't
bully okay that's good now you know for
again we have so many I calm not yet
Muslim because everyone has the
potential to submit their entire selves
to the one who created them that's what
a Muslim is what's aslam do yeah i was
going to define it I mean can you define
to us what is Islam well Aslam means I
some play peace and submission on these
peace so remember some words to
submitting to us time we're submitting
to peace and regularly peace to the
universe to all of our list of plants
animals humans and of course and we
worshiping Allah sapana Tyler so the one
who is the owner of peace the one who
gives peace is the creator of the
heavens in the earth so when we submit
ourselves to the one who created us this
is how we can give we can have peace
within ourselves and naturally we're
going to have peace with our environment
with the animals with the plans with
other human beings that's what Islam is
calling us to isn't that wonderful and
that's what a Muslim is one who does
Islam so now for those people who don't
know much about Islam you know what
they've learned some things here in a
Dean show and they're excited they come
back every week some of them maybe they
got their family members and they see
you with the hijab they might want to
know why she wearing that
well the high job is it obligatory to
you until you reach a certain age but I
started off when I was six because my
mom also started and I and I learned
that it wasn't that it's never young
when you want to start off something
good and you want and you want to do
something when you're young and you want
to do something good and it's never
young we need to have a young enough to
start it and doing it for that for a Las
Palma Tyler so he saw eaten because of
me ha yeah now have you heaven has
anybody ever given you a hard time
because of the hijab not most of us some
people ask me I for example do you have
any hair 19 of the questions like that
like a this is even lesser yes sir yes
um there are some song has some funny
questions but nine nobody really did
that yeah i'll share something with you
you know somebody asked the question you
know why do your women cover for
instance and did you hear the one about
the two candies the two pieces of candy
so the guy who was asked this he took
two pieces of candy and he threw him on
the floor it floor is like dirty got
dust over it right so then one was
unwrapped you know the candy has the
wrapper so one was with the wrapper and
one was without the wrapper so then he
told the person to ask him he said you
know which one would you like to pick up
off the floor now what do you think he
said the one that was uncovered now I
got all the dirt on it and all this
other stuff or the one that was wrapped
up sealed tight what do you think he
said the one that was wrapped up so then
the light bulb when I he said oh I see
ah and this is the Muslim woman our
mothers our daughters our aunts our
grant I mean the woman is more precious
than the candy or diamonds or any of
these things so it's LOM protects the
woman definitely yes and do you feel
more protected now why are you wearing
two hijab you feel more respected yes
why is that I'm because when people see
you and when you try to come early for
example when many am pleased upon I
would marry when she used to cover up
universe are uncovered that's the mother
of Jesus yes and whenever you saw her in
a picture people painted of her people
made of her she was always
cover it up and see none nowadays when
they're wearing their their clothes
people respect them more because they
think they're finally their religion
better than we are so if he if if Mary
peace be upon her madam Elya smile but
if she can do it and if Miss can do
hacking with someone can't do it how
come there's like a double standard
there on the moon does it suddenly she's
repressed yeah well that's true freedom
then you freedom within the bounds of
morality is dressing up instead of
dressing down you know so that should be
respected you choose to wear more and
that is something that you know what if
anybody looks at it logically it makes
sense and one of the most righteous
women you just mentioned her name Mary
the mother of Jesus she was wearing that
muslim hijab also you're doing the same
with the continuing the same legacy and
we're going to come back with more of
alia and we got a special guest here on
the Dean show too he'll be with us soon
Abraham so don't go nowhere here on the
Dean show with alia sit tight so I'm
like with good deeds will find that good
reads good peer out just remind in your
heart of hatred and preconceived notions
racism and nationalism because you
cannot have anything inside of you
that's like that against people and
still be successful
back here on the Dean show with alia and
we're going to continue on asking you
some questions all right so you know
there's a big thing in the media you
know that Islam is being portrayed like
it's something that is not good for
Humanity like it's something that is
extreme does Islam teach you to be
extreme no I does Islam teach you to be
radical no good in the slum did that may
different kind some listen from all them
all kind of out all all parts of the
world and we're always supposed to be
nice to everyone then including those
muscles down now does Islam teach you to
hurt innocent people to have this idea
that you want to hurt children people
who are not Muslim to want to kill them
actually I said I believe it's this
isn't cleaner and Heidi's um but it says
if you kill one person that's like you
killed the whole world and if you see
one person it's like you save what the
whole world okay so you're not i mean
you're not one of those radicals are you
okay we see we we find that funny now
there are you know we have to admit
there are some people who possibly you
know they have some misinformation but
that's why we encourage everyone to come
watch the Dean show read some of your
books to figure out really what the
Muslim you are all about and you know
you're somebody who's a testimony to
that thank you alright so we talked
about the job we talked about the
terrorism that Islam has nothing to do
with this and it's a shame that we have
to constantly usually come back to this
but again there's so many people out
there who love what Islam is about you
know what it makes sense we should just
God do good and and and get paradise
right so accountability for your actions
day of judgment all these things make
sense but then they hear something about
Psalms and in the news and the media and
then they get this elf taste in their
mouth but now they get to hear it from
us and you know what they think they
start thinking a little bit different
and many of them even accept Islam is it
true that more Muslim more women are
accepting Islam than men yes did you
hear about that yes I heard it yeah what
do you got to say about that well well
they're in the right in the world
actually there are more women than men
so McDowell is gonna be that I'm come to
LA okay role models is very important
nowadays the youth are taking bad people
as role models all right as their
leaders and you to get to where you were
today having you know masha'Allah this
knowledge who did you have to take as a
role model well I smooth my role models
are well as a sort of he was a great
leader helping kids and adults and he
used in my role models and another one
of my role models is part-owner yellow
hard hat she was also very brave and
courageous and she helped her father a
lot and his mission in the slam and some
other role models in this society today
that I think have done a lot for a slam
and so for the end to help out this
Muslim Ummah our example dr. Zakir Naik
shere ease of access dr. braheem jamali
dr. Tophet Charlotte many other great
chefs and scholars uh you know I ask you
some of these questions before I think
they're important now you know for some
of the kids that are taking Britney
Spears and JLo fifty cents you know
rough raw Brigadier I'd these people as
role models you know and they're
listening to you now why should they
take who you mentioned his role models
as opposed to taking these other people
as role models well well like to the
people that I took from Romano's they've
always had good characters they always
had good manners always had good um the
hello dough is getting good they were
always trying to do good helping other
people and most of these people some of
their songs
aren't very good and some of their songs
portray a bad message that kids as young
as me we shouldn't be listening to her
and we shouldn't really know about it we
stick to my our minds clean from these
things and so it's important to have
role models that I teach you got things
that are good and steps teaching you bad
things and teaching you worse things
then we're supposed to know at the same
age let's talk about respecting Islam
what does Islam teach you about respect
well slanty to disrespect to a las
palmas allah and from a las a bailout
respecting him expecting a god is I obey
His commandments and obeying what he's
telling us to do and from that we also
I'm will also have to respect all of my
kind Muslim or non-muslim so we have to
respect them and we also have to respect
plants and animals and other living
things that's beautiful Islam is giving
you a complete balance but the first
thing is you mentioned is respecting the
one who gave you life so you want to
worship Him alone what if someone says
look you know I worship a messenger like
Jesus I mean is that the right thing to
do no because even the messengers in
some point or another that always said
when they were stuck in something or
they had I get help they're always pray
to God there was patola they always went
back to a las panatela for a less than
to help us and to ask the last part that
for help so even they did always
surrendered themselves to a lost
paradise now when you say a loss on doll
are you talking about some moon god who
are you talking about when you say a
loss that's my bad that is to God who
created this universe and who created
everything in it and that's the one that
these messengers they called upon when
they were in need yes what now the next
question why were these messengers sent
why did God send all these messengers
well God created everything on my craft
and he created everything and he created
the world and he created a bit see in it
so he heated that and basically for I
want to give you an example of the
president but he made a car and the
vinings gasoline and the dent in his
energy I mean I didn't use that to say
and I use a whole new type of energy and
many people don't know how to use that
you're the only one that knew and would
you give a manual to help people use
that car or would you just let people
try to gas it up and break this part of
the
and and try to power it up and break
this other part or would you send manual
maybe even make a video teaching people
how to use this car well this one lost
when the talented he made us then he
sent down books and messengers to help
guide us to the one path that's going to
help us in this role this life and the
hereafter and there are some of these
pockets for example where Adam loot no
no us a smile as hacking many and Papa
Muhammad professor prophet musa and many
other prophets and messengers and they
were sent from a la scala Tyler and I
said that different times for different
tribes and but in the end they always
came with the one same message there's
only one message to all came with and
that was believing in one God believing
on 11 God yes that was the message from
all the prophets and what else and also
they also to treat your neighbors kindly
treat other people who kindly do
business fairly and many other things
like this so much so much to cover and
so little time so we're going to get
through all of this we promised the
people Abraham where's Abraham Abraham
salam aliko alia hey my seller I
watching a show I was really exciting
thank you oh I can ask you some
questions hey I also met your brother
give my salaams okay okay okay I'm kind
of hungry ah is it correct can i hmm no
that's a mic oh sorry I forget sometimes
uh tell me now like you know there's
some people they confuse they think
Islam is like Terry damn and worshiping
Mohammed and and and they want to burn
the car on what are you gonna say to
them is that what Islam is about like
terrorism and blow this person out on my
head sorry ah can you put my head back
down [ __ ] okay no no no tangent duck à
la right oh okay all right what do you
got to say to them please oh well as
farmer it well slump isn't about that
it's about peace and it's for peace for
all of mankind and for all
oh mashallah but you know how can you
get peace first what do you get what's
the first thing you gotta do [ __ ] I mean
what do you got to do to have peace well
there are five pillars in the sack ah
five pillars tell me the [ __ ] tell me
tell me tell me well the first pillar is
johana saying there was one god and that
he is a lost planet Allah and the second
pillar about is there a messenger you
would ask forgot is it what I there's
only one guide and what's what muhammad
the messenger yes and muhammad azam
assaulter go ahead keep on and then the
second pillar is I'm Salah so prank then
that solid Salah solo not started like
food or something so what does that mean
so I I'm salata knees prayer Oh prayer
prayer to God yes it's good why weren't
you pray to God so get a prayer just God
when you say a prayer to God in Jesus or
Mohammed or the moon or what are you
talking about wait a whole I'm praying
to one a lot prank on that ok go ahead
and then so that's a lot in then it's
I'm the cat giving alms giving charity
to the poor people who are in need of it
and then so fastening and that's the
that's the fourth pillar which is so on
which is fasting in the month of Ramadan
and also there is some fastening also
you could do if you don't have to but
you can do on Mondays and Thursdays so
I'm fasting and then there's hedge which
is the fifth pillar it's a pilgrimage to
where is out to Disney World no it's my
care ah Mecca ah that's like the first
house of worship by Abraham right after
worship work the Kaaba a to worship
Allah ought to worship God I like how
you answer that good I gotta go but I
want can you sis my head ok I gotta go
uh but I want to sing a song can you
sing a song with me okay i'm gonna start
and then you go are you ready and
everybody at home sing along have you
have you happy happy i love you Peggy
huggy huggy huggy I love you huggy huggy
huggy where you love me too huggy huggy
huggy
will you love me too i love allah and i
love you too I love Allah and I love you
too [ __ ] huggy huggy I love you how you
huggy huggy I love you ok sister I'm
going to go and make sure you do the hug
to your father and your mother and your
your brother and sister give them a hard
tell them you love them cuz we gotta
love each other all right ok I most
important what do you love the most I
last a lifetime oh you love God the most
that's not a salam aliko hello everybody
def and the day of judgment the mercy of
Allah these are the things that finally
made me realize there is no time to
delay anymore I wanted to take martial
heart a right day the essence of
spirituality is to become worse than
seattle last time I sounds fun to play
deck itself it is very very scary but it
brings you back to reality there is a
life which is everlasting in the graph
you have to make a conscious decision or
which group of people do you want to be
off the people having other people help
I'm not alone if Eliza I am not afraid
to stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone if allies by my side I am not
afraid to stand
I am not afraid to stand alone if a las
bombas I i am not afraid to stay
you
back here on the Dean show
and what you think about Abraham may be
funny you like his song yeah yeah so
encouraging to hug your parents okay hug
your mom haha alright so you covered now
with him the five pillars this is very
important that's that's the the bedrock
of Islam you know testifying that there
is no god but God that you only worship
the one who created you and Muhammad is
the last and final messenger and this
would accept you would accept all the
other message that came before him Jesus
Moses Abraham Noah then the prayer five
times a day the charity the fasting and
the Hajj and you know if anybody wants
to accept Islam you know this is what
they have to do it's very simple so
you've learned so much it's and so short
of time now let's move on we're almost
out of time tell us how lea you have
some tips that you give youth when you
speak what are these tips well the first
tip is always remember last panel
attalla and that he's always watching
you even if other people don't see you
and you do something bad and the second
thing is keep gaining knowledge about
great leaders so that you may emulate
them and the third tip is be an example
don't wait for everybody else to be the
good leader if you see the time to help
someone stop doing something bad help
them and the fourth tip is be humble
always be humble and this and always
help people out this may seem hard at
some crazy my mom told me that this is
truly one we show a lot propeller that
we love we love him and thank him for
his blessings and number five always say
I'll have the left for everything and
sometimes your chest or trial or
tribulation is hard remember that it
could always be worse really great
advice really great advice and how can
people if they want to read some of
those books that you have written how
can they get in touch with you well they
can go to my website www honoree combats
called a ly eight
and you are I calm so they can go to
that website and also on there's this
other website I have and I say this is
with me and my brother and it's home or
four kids were making games and
everything on that website and that
website is called www.kik.com again
that's www that thing's every kid should
know deca well thank you again for
joining us here on the Dean show I'm
sure so many people got the benefit and
sharla we'll see you again next time
you're in town thank you may Allah
reward you and thank you for tuning in
sitting tight through another episode of
the Dean show you got to learn a little
bit more about Islam Islam is the
fastest-growing way of life in the world
and Salaam doesn't call you doesn't call
the children doesn't call human beings
to go and kill other human beings if
style Islam is about establishing
justice Islam is about establishing
goodness in your homes and your
societies and you can see from the
little Muslims that we have this is what
the parents are teaching them Islam and
this is what's breeding good because
Islam is good and God is good in the
onlyest steps good and he set the best
message the best message humanity and
has to call human beings to establish a
direct dial up to have peace with the
one who created you and that's how you
can truly have peace within yourself and
you can have peace with the environment
and those around you and we hope we
really hope that you take the time out
continue to come back here to the Dean
show to continue in your quest because
there's a lot of things out there
distracting you but you taking the time
out you're reflecting what's the purpose
of life why am I here in this world and
you know what everything about Islam is
making sense there were some
misconceptions that you have but you
came to the Dean show and now you
understand why the Muslim woman covers
Jesus is mother covered Jesus wasn't God
but he prayed to god you're learning all
these things you learned the five
pillars of Islam makes sense it makes
sense it's something that you don't have
to do a lot of mental gymnastics to make
fit it's something that goes with your
very nature worship the One God do good
not just to Muslims to all mankind to
all mankind and there is one hadith that
will end what this is a saying of the
last
final messenger sent to mankind that he
is saying that those that do not have
mercy to God's creation to the creatures
on earth God will not have mercy on them
and Islam is a merciful religion it's a
merciful way of life and we hope that
inshallah God willing that you want to
know more and if you want to get a free
car on which the verbatim word of God
called the number on the screen 1 866 to
Islam and if you want to follow the way
of life all the messages of God
including Jesus go ahead and call even
if you have some criticism there are
welcome we can come to an understanding
to a healthy dialogue and until next
time peace be unto you i am not afraid
to stand alone I am Not Afraid you stand
alone if allies by my side I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid to
stand alone if Eliza
I am not afraid to stand alone
you